ready to go it's about the stream let's
see if this works
and i will let you know if i see it
hello i think i see it i see us there
our live love we are live
and i'll put a direct link in there
hello everybody out there welcome to
this special episode of what we call
brilliant minds and we are joined by
someone who's certain to be a brilliant
mind i've seen a lot of his work and
i've been meaning to meet him for a long
time i've actually seen
and produced an event about you uh or so
you know
including you and the chasing einstein
documentary
and that we did say that again fantastic
yeah so we did that uh about right
before the lockdown started
in uh in march i believe it was
okay we had a uh an event here with
elena april
and the kaishon knee who's my colleague
at uc san diego
um that was xenon one tone experiment
and then we had the filmmaker
of the chasing einstein documentary
which is available
on youtube and you can find it there
maybe i'll put a link in the show notes
but it's none other than dr james
beacham who is calling us
from uh central europe from the czech
republic
what used to be called czechoslovakia i
believe uh
and uh i contacted james uh for two
reasons one i've always wanted to talk
to you
followed you online not just for your
contributions in physics but also
you have a very strong gift at
popularizing what's known as
popularizing physics and making it
accessible
to the lay person and to the non-expert
i'm a lay person when it comes to
high energy particle experimental
physics myself
and so i find your ted talks and your
uh public outreach talks that you've
done as well as your films
uh i believe you were you also in um
in uh
particle fever particle fever uh in fact
my name is in the credits um
long story on particle fever but uh i
was in particle fever
in fact before the higgs discovery
particle fever um was a totally
different project
and they shot me and some other people
on two completely separate occasions
two completely amazing things that
because of the higgs discovery didn't
make it into the final film so
oh that's funny i know those guys quite
well but uh yeah
my name's in the credits if you look
closely oh that's great um
good so what we're gonna do today is
have a little conversation which is
prompted by
uh news from last friday uh in the uh
particle physics community about a
future collider
and before we get to your opinions as an
expert in the field i thought it would
be interesting for my
listeners to get some uh perspective
from you as an expert in this field
as to the importance of these
high-energy particle physics experiments
how they work at a basic level why
they're so important
uh why we need another one and why they
are so
darned expensive and why we don't have
them all in our
in our basements although i have a tiny
little particle accelerator called a
cathetery tube
that i keep around uh but james can you
um uh you have some slides i'm gonna
make you the co-host of this
let me see uh-oh let's see if i can do
this stop live stream no
oh i gotta go to participants bear with
me people
nobody's starting my second does it take
to uh operate zoom
it's only my fifth hour of zooming today
i used to joke that i studied the cosmic
microwave background and now i study the
cosmic zoom background
uh i bet you're in the same contact so
james you should have the power now
to stream live uh so take it away sir
let's try here what will it allow me to
do ah
great i should be able to share this and
you should be able to see some slides
yeah
yeah i see a large blue set of
alternating tubes yeah exactly what
happens if i get a full screen does it
ruin everything
can you see things i think i still see
it
try advancing one slide just to make
sure it works yeah perfect advanced one
slide okay great
fantastic perfect yeah awesome great
cool take it away
sir yeah first of all it's really great
to be here i'm really happy that
you reached out to me um because you
know a couple of reasons one is it's a
very very exciting time
in particle physics and just in physics
and society in general
and you know the other part is of course
that because of the pandemic you know my
my sort of like second life the ultra
hobby is like
you know talking to the public and that
kind of a thing and i haven't had a
chance to do that for a while so
so this is a good opportunity to kind of
you know get back into that mode
um yeah i've heard all these celebrities
are all bummed out because you know the
job of
instagram personality is not as
lucrative as it used to be
exactly no it's a part of it is gone but
i mean
so the the you know it's the most
important reason why
you know it's it's awesome that uh we
get to have this conversation today is
that
from my perspective you know this kind
of this the cern announcement on friday
that uh
that they're seriously considering you
know sort of like there's called this
european strategy for the future of
particle physics it's this europe
european version of you know something
that's going on right now in the us
called the snow mass process
similar similar to chart the course of
the the next you know
half a decade decades many decades to
come for particle physics and priorities
i mean it's so exciting because what
came out of that sort of prioritization
document
a bunch of fantastic ideas that really
deserve feasibility studies like really
honest to god feasibility studies and
that's really what we're seeing right
now
and a lot of people in europe i mean i'm
you know i'm an american but i've lived
in
lived in switzerland for like what six
years now right and so a lot of people
in europe have been
sort of like just twiddling their thumbs
waiting for this type of thing to come
out
to really understand like you know what
are going to be the priorities and so
you can really dive in to
just you know to work on some of these
things and one of the big
the big uh you know the big ideas that
they threw some weight behind was this
notion of a future circular collider
right so this is
the fcc i hope that they change the name
when the future becomes the present
right but
the uh you know the fcc is this idea of
being something like you know a hundred
kilometer new tunnel
dug dug on the border of france and
switzerland no
and it would be it would hopefully reach
something like a hundred tera electron
volts and the current large hadron
collider gets to 13 terra electron volts
so this is something like you know four
times as big a collider
it isn't even dug yet and it would read
something like six times the energies of
what we can do right now at the large
hadron collider
and that the prospect of that is
absolutely
mouth-watering i mean every particle
physicist is like oh my goodness what
could i do with this
it's so good to see the excitement
around this idea
and uh uh you know and and people have
been thinking about it for a long time
and finally to see it sort of like get
this sort of it's weird because the
the european strategy this document that
came out it's a little bit kind of
you know it has to be somewhat judicious
and diplomatic so i can't say we're
doing this it's more like
we should do it's a good idea to do a
feasibility study about so-and-so thing
and so this is the idea that now is a
you know the fcc
has kind of graduated from just an idea
idea to like a real idea
and that's why it's so exciting right
now because the prospect of 100
kilometer tunnel and 100 tev hadron
collider is
absolutely you know gobsmacking what you
could do with this and so that's why
for me you know it's it's it's
interesting because right now
in the history of science i as far as i
can tell there's never been a better
time
to be a physicist there's never been a
better time to be a curious human being
and if you're into it if you're into you
know concrete reasons and lists and
things like that it comes from this
physicist
as you know we're like problem solvers
right we we see something that's weird
and we go out and try to like figure out
a reason for why
we're never satisfied with someone
telling us oh that's just the way it is
that's completely dissatisfied we don't
we don't know we want to know why
we want to know a mechanism we want to
test the hell out of it we want to
figure out all these things
and so that's why for me right now is an
extremely important time
exciting time to be alive because look
at the number of burning questions and
answers in physics that are open for us
to
to address and to possibly solve in
physics right now
and you see that this is basically the
exact same list prior to 2012
2012 of course of the large hadron
colliders when we discovered this higgs
boson particle this fantastic discovery
that
you know we there's something like six
thousand of us make hooray but
again the only if you look closely at
this slide the very very top right uh
left corner
there's only one thing that has been
checked off here all the rest of these
are completely open
questions and this is amazing because it
also
indicates that we have entered a brand
new era
in particle physics we are no longer
guided only by theoretical
considerations
and that's totally bizarre for people
right now and honestly it's something
that
even experimentalists we have to sort of
like retrain our brains we have to
re recalibrate what it means to be a
particle physicist because we were all
raised on the same books and and we were
we were all
uh taught by the same textbooks that
teach about the
history of 20th century physics where
you know somebody will come up with some
weird observation on a test
tabletop experiment and then somebody a
theorist will say that's interesting
maybe it means this
and then it'll go back and forth and
there was this kind of very clear
flashlight as to where you should
you know build the next uh experiment to
make the discovery
and it kind of happened just like
clockwork throughout the 20th century
and it this happened all over and over
you know even into the you know the late
70s when
these w and z bosons these particles
that were completely
game changers that it demonstrated this
strength of this thing called the
standard model as you probably know
the standard model of particle physics
that indicated that it's basically the
set of equations that you can write down
and you kind of turn the crank on them
and they spit out precise predictions as
to what you should see in particle
physics experiments
and overwhelmingly they're spot on and
it's such a successful theory and you
know for example it more or less
predicted these w and z bosons back in
the 70s and they were right there
waiting for us so this is sort of like
clockwork it's very much it was very
much
theory driven for decades in particle
physics up to and including
the higgs boson discovery because as you
know in this 27 kilometer circular
tunnel
on the border of france in switzerland
so let's back up a second what is the
large hadron collider the large hadron
collider is a 27 kilometer circular
tunnel
on the border of france and switzerland
buried about 100 meters underground and
in this tunnel we use superconducting
magnets that we have to keep colder than
outer space
to accelerate protons you're basically
made of protons
to almost the speed of light and then we
smash these into each other millions of
times a second
and we collect a record of the debris
that flies out and we
build the build up the largest unique
data set in human history and we sift
through this unique data set to try to
find evidence of things we weren't
expecting
and before the large hadron collider in
the same tunnel we had something called
lap
which is the large electron positron
collider and this thing was looking very
closely for a lot of things
and it started to see like a little bit
of a hint of the higgs
higgs boson but it was nothing
conclusive whatsoever
and so this is sort of like the it was
but a lot of the indirect measurements
that the
the lep was making and other tevatron
experiments and fermilab and other
things a bunch of indirect measurements
were suggesting to us that there should
be a higgs boson particle
sort of just around the corner in energy
and that's
just you know it but it was sort of just
a suggestion right i mean it's it's
more or less indirect suggestions hints
that we get from theory
calculations combined with experimental
uh measurements which is again the whole
history of the 20th century physics was
like that
so then everybody built this large
hadron collider colliding protons
instead of electron positron
and lo and behold right around the
corner there was a higgs boson particle
about 125 gev
uh oh just for people this is a nice
animation i hope you can see the
animation
so this is really what it looks like you
know an animation for what the
the lhc really does you take these
protons
and at some point you're going to zoom
down inside like it's a star wars movie
or something like that
oh here it comes there you go
and again so you accelerate these
protons to almost the speed of light
and they slam them into each other
millions of times a second the place
where you slam them into each other you
build a gigantic detector
because quantum field theory magic is
going to happen and by gigantic i mean
gigantic like the one that i work on is
called atlas
and it's six stories high and it's 46
meters long
and it's it deserves the name atlas is
gigantic uh and you know
this is the type of the the extent to
which we have to go to collect all this
debris
and this is sort of like you know this
is a i put this up here just because it
gives you a
you know a sense of something we use a
lot in our experiments or
in our analysis called event displays
this is what you would this is sort of
like a
this is in fact a rendering of what a
collision looked like
so this is when uh two protons one came
into the screen and one went out of the
screen
and they collided in the middle and they
made this fuzz and a bunch of stuff flew
out so this is the sort of thing that we
look at all the time
um and then so you know a lot of this
stuff is
it seems a little bit like arcane um and
before i get to the standard model part
and why we need these sort of things
i'll just kind of like back up a second
because
you know you see you hear about this
sort of thing you hear about why you
know
you see like oh yeah 27 kilometer tunnel
protons being collided together blah
blah but
the question should still be at the back
of your head if you're not a if you're
not
uh you know an expert why are they doing
this
that's a very important question right
and even though for me you know
even me i sometimes like to remind
myself you've been doing this for a long
time
although what we do is not so super
arcane because at the end of the day it
all comes down to for me
a sliced bagel so i'm sort of an adopted
new yorker now that's my home base back
in the u.s
so i take a bagel and i cut it in half
and then i cut the half in half
and i keep going how far can i go i get
to a crumb can i cut a crumb yeah i
eventually get to a molecule can i cut a
molecule yeah there's atoms inside there
can i cut an atom yeah there's a nucleus
and an electron can i
cut an electron it turns out as far as
we know now the answer is no
but can i cut a proton yes it turns out
there's stuff
inside of a proton can i cut the stuff
inside of the proton as far as we know
now
no so this is really the entire it turns
out that when you ask just like a lot of
physics when you ask a seemingly
simple question like how small can i cut
anything
you're secretly asking a much more
complicated question which is what was
holding anything together
to begin with and so then this is again
the thing i mentioned the standard model
the whole interplay between theory and
experiment in the 20th century led to
this thing called the standard model of
particle physics which is really just
this list of particles known
elementary uncuttable particles that we
know exist and the ways that they
interact
and that's pretty much it and this last
missing piece this was the thing that
was missing the higgs boson it was just
it was predicted like in the 60s
and people have been looking for it for
a very long time and no one had any idea
where it was going to be because the
standard model
for all of its awesomeness all of its
successes it made one it was
had one really really frustrating thing
about it it said that the higgs boson
exists
but it doesn't tell you anywhere about
where it should be and that's
frustrating because
that that where it should be is related
to its mass you know how massive a
particle is which is related to this
higgs field
idea but anyway this last piece of the
higgs boson
of the standard model we plugged in was
this thing called the higgs boson
particle
it was discovered in 2012 and you know
led to
a nobel prize for two white males what
else is new and so you know this is
this is this is this is a fantastic
discovery
but the problem is that we know for a
fact that the
the standard model is incomplete and i
think you know this and i think a lot of
your your uh
your you know audience would know this
too but we know that it can't be the
full and complete picture of
of of the universe and so we go in
search of these new particles
that will help us explain some of the
big open questions that we have
in physics right now and this really
comes in the way we look for these
things really comes down to einstein as
you know so this is e equals m c
squared his famous relation so m is
the thing that nature controls nature
controls the mass of a particle and as
you know
mass for particles not the same thing
that we use the word mass
in like colloquial language like oh look
at that massive airplane
mass for a particle is just an intrinsic
property of a particle
it's like charge or spin it's just a
number put there by nature we don't
control it
we can only measure it the part we can
control if we work hard enough as
physicists
is the e part and this is the energy or
kinetic energy of particles that we can
slam into each other and so you see that
when we're doing this and sometimes
you'll see it measured in tev like i
said you see that when we're doing this
what we're doing is we're going to
extremely high energies to try to
kick back into existence very briefly
particles that maybe only existed just a
fraction of a second after the big bang
13.8 billion years ago
that's you know again i don't have to
tell you but maybe some of your audience
you know to remind them the universe
right now is extremely huge
and it's also on average extremely cold
if i take a temperature a thermometer
put it out into the outer space
it's going to be extremely low
temperature something like 2.1
2.7 kelvin or something like that that's
very very very low energy
and on average the entire energy of the
universe is very very low right now
but it was not always this way we know
that every the universe is expanding
you just run the clock back at some
point back in the uh back
far uh la you know back in time
everything in the universe had to have
been packed into a tiny dense little
area
or a little volume and particles do not
like it when you start to smack them
together like that they start to vibrate
and they start to you know radiate and
they start to you know go wild
and the average temperature of the
universe goes very high
so there's this inverse relationship
between temperature and energy
temperature
sorry temperature and time and
temperature is related to energy
and when we go that's what we do when we
collide protons or
anything in the in a collider experiment
we're briefly recreating the conditions
of the universe as they were
just a fraction of a second after the
big bang 13.8 billion years ago
so in fact it is a sort of a big bang
machine that we're doing that's the
reason it's in a very controlled way
we're not going to make a
black hole to suck in the earth or
anything but we can we can slightly
hopefully coax into existence any
particles that maybe the universe
doesn't have so much use for right now
that would help us explain the big open
questions that we see
right now and so you know that's the
kind of that's that's the reason why
and to answer your question why we have
to go to bigger machines because bigger
machines you know you see in my slide
right here the large hadron collider can
get us to right there
about what 10 to the minus what is a 10
to the minus 12 10 minus 20 seconds
something like that
but that means that all the interesting
stuff is back farther in time
we got to build bigger machines bigger
energies to ever
hope to understand what was going on
back at that moment
i don't know if you wanted to say
anything else here i can keep going but
yeah i wanted to say one thing you know
just again my my role is
both a cheerleader and uh a gentle numb
tomato throwing
critic often i've heard this you know we
want to get back to the beginning of
time
of course yeah the highest energy ever
if we are you know right as many
cosmologists think that inflation took
place
you're talking about you know 10 to the
16th gev
and higher many orders of magnitude
maybe a trillion times
higher than the current lhc and just far
beyond the
the reach of even the future collider so
is there
interesting physics that can be
discovered in this you know
in this no scientist land between what
we have reached with
with cern's lhc currently and where the
fcc could get to or is it just you know
kind of a little because
the energy scales are some very steep
power of of the radius of the collider
right so um
or the one over that so the question is
um can you really learn about the early
universe this is one of the criticisms i
hear most uh
the real early universes was a plasma
perhaps of you know quarks and
and weakly interacting particles so far
inaccessible to the to at least the lhc
is it really any hope or is it just yeah
bigger is better
you get more energy you get higher
temperature but you're kind of
diminishing returns
yeah the answer for from me as an
experimentalist
is it doesn't matter and i know that's
maybe like a provocative statement but
as an experimentalist again that's
partly partially what i mean by
we're in the process right now after the
higgs discovery we're in the process of
recalibrating ourselves
as experimentalists exploratory
physicists rather than
uh being guided by a theory flashlight
because again those three flashlights
are sort of like
you know they're kind of dying out and
they have been for a while again i
completely love all my theory colleagues
i want the best you know i want the best
ideas from them i
really do this i want to make that very
clear i love all my theory colleagues
100
to death but we're not guided anymore by
the big kind of like
you know big flashlights again it's like
oh there should be a higgs right around
the corner
because of the you know because of the z
mass and the you know the top mass and
that kind of thing
and and we're not guided by you know the
the past where it's like wow we see this
little enhancement there should be like
a wimp
at about you know 2 gev or something
like that and that's obviously not there
you know at least at
uh cross sections that we can we can
understand
so these big theory hints are kind of
not so
clear anymore however the big open
questions still remain
so that requires us to recalibrate
ourselves as exploratory mindset rather
than you know
it's like experiment first theory later
and that
requires us to go back to just the bare
bones bear basics in terms of quantum
field theory in terms of you know
particle physics general properties of
particles
and in that case what i said about this
this slide here of course as you pointed
out is very very theory-based
the time part is not so well understood
and so
the in its and what actually happened
before this kind of time
time scale is very theory dependent so
one theorist will have one idea another
theorist will have another idea
and again as experimentalists our job is
not to
you know demonstrate whether theorists
are guessing correctly our job is really
to explore the unknown
that's really what we do i like to think
of it excuse me i like to think of
us as experimentalists we're like
cartographers we're not re my job is not
really to discover new particles
my job is to is to map out all the
possible places in data and parameter
space
where a new discovery could be hiding
and if i don't do that i haven't done my
job
as a as a as a jump fro you know so as a
corollary to that if we as a species
don't explore places we've not explored
before
we're not doing our job as curious
humans so you know it's kind of a
backhanded way to answer your question
but the
the real the answer is that really i
don't know i don't know who to who to
trust
about what should happen before this
time period i mean
in a in a very broad sense as you said
if we wanted to get to the uh you know
we wanted to do the job right and in
fact i have more slides about that too
it's
you know i like to give talks about this
uh this idea of building
uh you know a particle collider around
the outer edge of the solar system right
to hopefully
reach the plot scale and hopefully not
create a black hole to just suck in the
experiment itself right
we we confronted that a few years ago
right yeah
exactly we survived the black hole
potential uh fatality
okay good yeah let's keep going there
will be some more questions i think that
that the audience is going to ask but um
but yeah i think
yeah sorry go ahead no no i think that i
think that's fair i mean i i often point
out
as in my book i point out a lot of the
grey's discoveries were serendipitous
discoveries in science and
you know in some sense the higgs i mean
if you're not guided by physics
i mean you probably would have bet if
not your life you know your cat's life
or you know uh you know your your new
your new smartphone's life or something
on the existence of the higgs it was so
well established it almost had to be
there and it was just really
narrowing down not where is it on the
three-dimensional
you know planet that we live on the
surface of that three-dimensional planet
but exactly you know the exact borders
of that of that
parameter space but now we're it's kind
of things are wide open
and without a lower limit like we had
lower limits on the higgs mass as far as
i understand we had upper limits we
really didn't have a great detection
like similar to the way we are with
neutrino mass right now we
we understand that they have a lower
limit we from theory and from
oscillation experiments um and we
understand there's an upper limit from
cosmic experiments and collider
experiments
but we don't know their exact math so
that makes it a very delicious
delectable
appetizer for for experimental
cosmologists and particle physics
because
you know it's there somewhere and it is
not serendipitous in that the way that
the nutri you know the neutrino was
predicted theoretically or
uh yeah came out as a consequence of a
theory but
the question i have is yeah i mean you
know counting on serendipity is often
pretty risky
and so it sounds like they're i mean can
you say there's a specific target
for an fcc or it's bigger is better
again i keep going back to that
main question that i think about well so
yeah the same problems in cosmology
yeah for sure i mean i can give you my
personal feeling of course and i can
give you the the
sort of the cern document right which
has you know what hundreds if not
thousands of my colleagues that worked
on this to kind of like
uh lay out what the priorities are and
what the possible things you could
possibly discover and i don't know i
don't think we have time to go through
all of them but
right a couple of the things that jump
out to me are
you know the well okay let's start with
the concrete first
so the concrete thing that everybody
wants to know the answer to is also
related to the higgs boson so we go back
to that standard model right
and it's sort of this you know this nice
tight box with this
set number of 17 particles and the way
they interact
and we know that there have to be
extensions to that it can't be the full
picture there have to be extensions to
that so we go into
search for example new forces of nature
that could connect dark matter
to ours this new force could could be
accompanied by a force-carrying particle
just like all the other forces are
so we go in search of these things like
dark photons or z primes at extremely
high
high energies that we just don't have
access to at the moment
that kind of a thing and so that's one
of the simplest ways that you can
you can look for new things is really
just we have we don't know what's there
we're out of big theoretical hints and
so we have to look otherwise
we'll never know and that's really the
way that what it comes down to
the other part the real answer the more
kind of diplomatic answer
again i'm the hardcore kind of like you
know empiricist type you know person is
like just show me i want to look
i don't trust it until i look but the
the other part is that the higgs boson
itself
is not so well understood and then this
is of course you know people that
that raise eyebrows about you know such
a big experiment they're like well is
the higgs boson really that important
the answer is yes it is absolutely
important
because it's the only i mean a lot of
your you know audience will know this
but it's
it's still it's worth reminding
ourselves what a bizarre particle this
is
it's the only it's the particle that
indicates that there's at least
one scalar field that permeates the
entire universe
completely it's the concrete evidence
that we have with that and it's
completely fascinating
and the boson part the particle itself
is you know you can think of it sort of
like a little vortex in this field it's
like you smack reality just enough and
it makes this little vortex big pig's
boson that then
uh decays back into the vacuum in a bit
but
the whole interplay of the whole
theoretical understanding of what the
higgs boson is
is not at all well understood and it
will never be completely understood to
our satisfaction
at the large hadron collider and that's
important
because the higgs boson in fact could be
that one little portal or this sort of
kind of like connection
to this other stuff that we don't
understand so in a very very easy way so
the higgs boson
has all these kind of particular you
know particular parameters within a
little kind of intricacies
and we have to measure each one of those
very very precisely otherwise
we'll never really know number one
whether the higgs is a
is the connection to the portal you know
is the portal to new physics
also from a you know if i can jump ahead
you know from also kind of an
existential perspective because let's
you know let's be honest those of us
that do particle physics and we do
astrophysics and things
the questions we're asking are extremely
philosophical behind the scenes you know
no one wants to say that and a lot of
like you know professors will
get mad at me for saying these things
but really we're asking the questions
where did we come from
how does everything work around us and
where are we going and the thing that's
totally unknown
now is what is the shape of the higgs
boson potential
i don't know if if anybody wants to yeah
well well we should get into that but
before we do
uh james there's some questions coming
in from xavi and brian
uh and they would like to know is it
possible to build a collider in space
and if so would a linear collider be
better a circular collider
how would it uh which is which is better
well to answer that question let me go
through a bit of my slides here so again
this is kind of the stuff that i just
talked about you know we jumped into the
we jumped we did about half energy at
the lhc got up to another higher energy
this dark matter open
question we can talk a bit about
multiverse theory two which i like to
harp upon
in my talks and then the idea is that we
have new colliders and so to kind of
answer the question
is all these ideas for next generation
colliders they all have pluses and
minuses and that's really
that's the real question that's going
forward and that's the question that the
european strategy
was trying to answer it was trying to
really kind of scratch
everyone's heads really you know really
uh terribly and say okay
what is the best way to understand these
questions
within a reasonable amount of time and
with with a reasonable budget too and
that's a very very difficult thing to do
and this is not just some pig and a poke
i mean this is you know
the entirety of the european physics
community and you know european
related physics physicist community
comes together to
do this collectively this is not just
like one person saying i think this is
interesting
this is everybody arguing arguing
arguing about their
their favorite pro project so the idea
is that we have this
and this again i promise that i'm
answering the question but
the you know we go back to the way you
know it also relates to the thing you
said brian too is like how
you know how how can we justify going to
these bigger machines
if you don't have if you run out of you
know big theoretical hints
you know these big flashlights if we're
out of those how can we justify
purely from exploratory purposes and the
answer is that it's always worked in the
past
so for example you can you know back in
the in 1897
tom thompson could discover the electron
by himself on a tabletop
and then we you know then started things
started to get a little bit bigger you
know in the 1950s this so-called proton
synchrotron at cern
628 meters around and then right now i'm
going to show like the relative size of
these different uh experiments so you
for example you had thompson
discovered the electron and down the
bottom you see what was actually
discovered when you go to a bigger
machine
so then we had something called the
alternating gradient secretron of
brookhaven and this is where the charm
cork was discovered
which is a complete game changer because
it took this idea
that what was inside uh things like
protons
was not just a heuristic but real it was
not just like a
bookkeeping technique but it quarks and
gluons are really real things
then you go to a bigger machine like the
super proton synchrotron and discover
the w and z bosons right there waiting
for you
and you go to the tevatron which is
around the same size and you discovered
the top quark
the last the heaviest particle that we
know exists in the standard model
and then you go to a bigger machine
which is the large hadron collider and
there was the higgs boson
so this happens all the time you build a
bigger machine you coax new things out
of the out of the out of the woodwork
that you can
that you can study and these new
discoveries we have no idea what the
next discovery is going to be
so for example this idea is that maybe
there's also going to be a chinese
collider that takes place in china the
cepc uh this is planned to be made for
the 2040s and it'd be something like 50
to 70 kilometers around
and this idea of course that's what
we're talking about now is this future
circular collider something like 80 to
100 kilometers around
but my idea is that you have to think
about these things
in the process of sort of in the history
of human inquiry these are not just
there's nothing magic about these
there's nothing magic about 27
kilometers
there's nothing we're not talking about
like a pretzel-shaped collider toroidal
colliders
right it's linear circular that's
basically it yeah it's equals mc squared
you go as big as you can
you try to get the biggest energy you
can so you can hopefully discover new
things
and so my my idea is that we should you
know build something that goes around
the moon because then you you know
around the circumference of the moon
because then you could potentially get
up to uh something like tens of
thousands of
tev and maybe coax things into existence
so you never had any idea
so the idea of building something in
space is entirely possible and so
people have also talked about it very
very far future things like you could
build like a linear collider floating in
space between the earth and the moon or
one of the kind of like uh
what are those called the the special
points uh you know in the in space where
you know
the everything's really really stable so
you can
build one of those things um those are
going to be extremely expensive at the
moment so when i give a talk like this
you know about building a collider
on the moon the take-home messages i
have no idea how much it's going to cost
but it's going to cost a lot of money
and so therefore it's probably for a
future future you know
uh civilization or maybe you know if we
were to get smart we could do it now
but you know if we wanted to make some
kind of ultra hadron collider we could
do it around the circumference of the
moon
but the possibility of building
something in space is people you know
people have done
you know very kind of back of the
envelope possibilities of this and again
it seems
very much probably a next century thing
it doesn't really seem like something
that within the next few decades it
could
could
really be done but i don't rule it out
just because you know i mean the
the title of your podcast right into the
impossible right
i mean impossible impossible is only
impossible up until the moment someone
makes it possible
exactly that's exactly sir arthur's
quote which we'll get to at the very end
i want to save a couple of minutes
at the very end to ask you questions uh
particular to you and
not related to this fcc etc so let's
keep going
and i hope we can have a couple minutes
at the very top of the hour
i'm not sure if i did yes no i think i
think that was good yeah and i this
image here with the moon that's a very
interesting one
to uh to set the scale of things because
there is of course an upper limit at
least to uh
to colliders based on earth and uh other
small planetoids
so yeah let's keep going with this one
i'm gonna keep going past that yeah no
uh well you can just mention this one
though
so yeah if for example you know the
reason i came up with this idea you know
i like to give this talk at
various places about a big bang machine
on the moon you know someone
at least the good audience is some
really smart kid will say you know why
don't you just build that like on the
earth around asia
and i'm like find me one eleven 000
kilometer circle
in asia that is politically non-fraught
it's not possible to do
and i think that with our interest you
know there's a lot of interest in going
back to space you've got spacex you've
got the the
bezos thing you know and there's a lot
of people interested in going back there
so why not just really make it happen
why not take advantage of people wanting
to go back to the moon where they
don't really know what they're going to
do on the moon so why don't we build a
big science center we could do
gravitational wave astronomy we could do
you know direct observational you know
visible
but oh i don't know if we want to talk
about that right now but
i i wanted to go through let me very
quickly go
through this thing i'll talk about that
in a second so but to really do the
the question really do the thing right i
mean let's be honest
if we really wanted to basically
understand everything about particle
physics right now the big open questions
maybe not everything but if we really
wanted to do it right we would just go
to the ultimate energy beyond which our
understanding of physics
kind of breaks down right and this is
the plonk energy and if anybody knows
the block energy this is basically prop
max planck took the a bunch of constants
of nature and arranged them in
dimensional ways
and come up with these these uh these
ranges beyond which
uh quantum mechanics and gravity have to
have something to do with each other
and that's one of the biggest open
questions right now how do quantum
mechanics and gravity work together
and currently they don't and we don't
have any evidence on how they could work
together if you really wanted to do it
right
you by some very very naive estimates
you would have to build
a collider around the outer edge of the
solar system which
i don't think this is going to happen
anytime soon or we're going to need some
major innovation to make this happen
but maybe you have a particularly
innovative audience so you know if
anybody has any ideas
or deep pockets are very deep pockets
so that's to really do it right we would
we would want to go to a very very big
machine
um but again that's that's that's sort
of you know
again i like to think of it in in terms
of the the
human progression the human curiosity
progression we have to look here
otherwise we'll never
know and really that's i you know i hate
to keep harping upon that but that's
really the answer at the end of the day
our job is not to validate some theory
our job is no
at least it no longer is because we're
out of those those big flashlights as to
what to uh you know how to build a big
machine
and so we really need to go as big as
possible and as it stands now something
like a 100 kilometer tunnel
is pretty good and it could be done
within a few decades and so that's
that's partially why people are
you know why it became a benchmark and
why people are kind of really pushing
into
into that direction and you can go
through all the standard uh you know the
theoretical motivations i mean super
symmetry for example
yes it's entirely that's a good example
right super symmetry you know as
most people know you have this standard
model which is all the known particles
which is this thing here
and you pause posit that there's another
copy of that that's over here
where the spins have just been changed a
little bit so there's this this last
remaining symmetry of nature
there's a lot of symmetries of nature
that a lot of symmetries in our
mathematics that nature either follows
or does not follow and it's not up to us
to
you know to say yes or no we have to
test it and see if it does and so we
there's this last one between bosons and
fermions that's related to spin
and there could be this other copy of
particles except we have no idea where
their masses are
we thought you know back before the lhc
a lot of people were like well
could be some super symmetry particles
also around the higgs boson and in fact
that's one of the other main things
about the higgs boson
that makes people a bit weirded out so
you mentioned earlier brian
that the higgs mass sort of like we had
a lower limit and we sort of had an
upper limit but
really there's nothing in this standard
model to prevent the higgs mass from
being something gigantically high in
fact at the planck scale there's nothing
really to prevent that
you can you can work hard and you can
say okay well it's natural to be a blah
blah place but there's nothing really to
prevent it from being gigantically high
but we found it down at the
down at the lhc 125 gev that's really
small
and it's in fact really strange so it
makes us start to think weird things
about the higgs boson and so therefore
you know it's entirely possible that
there are new particles within you know
a few hundred tv
that could explain uh why the higgs
boson mass is the way it is we don't
know until we look
very good okay yeah you want to keep
going
yeah please what do you want you want to
go keep going questions or want me to
keep talking
uh keep you why don't you keep going
with your presentation i'm going to look
up the questions
and i'll let you know if we have new
ones coming in let's see oh so this is
just a you know there's an article that
we did in gizmodo they did a really good
article about
uh they had this interesting series
where um
they're like ultimate experiment and
they wanted to ask uh different
scientists what would you do
if you had no limitations on resources
and uh you know
it has to be physically possible but you
know what would what would be the
ultimate experiment and i was like oh
particles collider around the outer edge
of the solar system and so this is a
good article that goes into some of the
details up there
and this is something that i think is
you know that underscores the point
quite nicely because
again what we're doing is exploring the
unknown we have unanswered questions
period and we don't know how to answer
them anymore we have hints they're you
know a couple of maybe
slight theoretical hints they're just
not as strong as they were so again we
have to switch our brains
from the theory chasing mindset to the
exploration mindset
and that's really where we are right now
and so for example
i would love in the future you know one
of the things that i would love if we
ever make contact with an alien
civilization
the first thing that i want to know is
like oh did you just what was your mass
of the higgs boson how big of a collider
did you do
you know did you discover did you
discover the x and the y bosons or these
uh particles these things that are
supposed to demonstrate the unification
of electro weak and strong forces
together you know did you reach the
plung scale these these kinds of things
right what was their history their world
line to getting there well you should
know you're not the
first uh physicist to talk about um
solar system size scale
uh objects that we had on freeman dyson
one of our first and many many uh uh
frequent guests throughout our episode
we miss them dearly
fantastic i always i very often get
asked about dyson spears when i
spears when i give talks and i give you
know talk about these people ask
because you get really people you know
that's the thing that i that i in fact i
find quite heartening
you know so there's within the particle
physics community ourselves
you know people that are working on
these experiments we do a lot of hemming
and high and it's like uh what's the
best experiment
you know because kind of to kind of go
back to one of the answers of somebody
else
um or is one of the other things that
one of the questions that came up
you know you don't have to do a circular
collider in fact one of the other things
you can do is a linear collider
um one of the benefits of a circular cut
well there's pluses and minus to all
these all these things right so when you
have a circular collider you can reuse
the particles that don't collide
because you know in the large hadron
collider i mean when i say that we
collide protons the picture you should
have in your head is not like
a line of ants going bing bing bing
that's not what happens at all
no way we could do that instead you have
two gigantic swarms of protons
and they kind of pass through each other
and overwhelmingly nothing happens and
these are not just a few protons this is
10 to the power
11 10 to the power 11 protons and they
overwhelmingly see equivalent current in
amps james
that's a good question no that's that's
a tough one i would say
i remember it being a large number but
i've forgotten exactly what i did yeah
the cross section for an image of a
proton that you know has
units of barns or whatever but barns are
extremely small
exactly and one scale so yeah right
exactly so
someone's asking now uh is that dyson
sphere
size is that really even practical how
could you get supply out there well
let's leave that to
kardashev you know type two
civilizations but
but one saying uh kuma's asking why
waste money
okay i'm not his words or her words not
mine i waste money on a bigger collider
we don't even know the theoretical
limits
as to how much energy we need i'm all
for scientific progress but we also need
to use reason and wisdom
just my honest opinion no it's a it's a
very good question it's a valid
point and i i would answer that i do
think that we the
the community the particle physics
community is using logic and reason
and wisdom behind this because for the
reasons that i indicated right it's like
anytime you've gone to a bigger collider
in the past something has shown up
and so this is really this kind of
guides us as experimentalists
that we need to just explore we need to
go as big as possible
and that is wise because it's always
worked in the past and again it goes
down to this thing where if we don't
look we'll never know we will not know
the answer to whether or not there are
say
you know 40 gev sorry 40 tev
squirks and gluey knows we will never
know the answer to that until we bigger
build a bigger collider once we do know
whether even if they don't show up
that's new information and it's a huge
success and that's the thing it's like
the large hadron collider you know
overwhelmingly all of the papers that we
that we publish like 99.99 of them have
been
null results verifications that the
standard model
is correct right that's good every
single one of those papers we should
have a breathless press conference about
it
because it's new information about the
universe that we didn't have before
so every single one of these is a
gigantic success so
that i guess it's always you know it's
always ruling out one question i have
because uh and i'll
assert my uh my moderator's privilege
here
uh is um we and we speak about big
experiments and we say
um we say that the that the you know
expense of a project is going to be
100 million dollars we're usually not
including
the cost to operate it which as a rule
of thumb the department of energy
typically will use something like 10 of
construction costs per year
so if you have a 20 billion dollar 20
billion euro
collider it's going to cost 2 billion
per year minimum so if you run it for a
decade
you're talking about doubling the cost
when when i see numbers we see numbers
like 21 billion a year is that including
operations or is that just project
construction
um that's a good question i think the 20
billion
is you know i don't know i'd have to go
back and look at that the number they
got quoted in some of the news stories
i'm not sure if that
that includes some operation as well i
think it does not because
but i think that the operation is not
quite as large as
what you indicate here too for example i
mean i can go back and it also
addresses the previous questions which i
don't think we answered you know
sufficiently
i apologize for that but here's an
example let me put it this way so yeah i
think that you
do have to factor in the operation costs
and i think it's also related to you
know
one of the differences between particle
physics and astrophysics for example or
astronomy right
you can build a big maybe you want to
talk about that later you know the the
you can have these observatories and
they cost a certain amount to put up
but it's not so much to continue to
operate you know
it's very different for the large
address collider experiments
but here's to sort of put these costs in
perspective because i totally agree let
me let me be completely honest
when you see a 20 billion euro price tag
on something you know you should
on a science experiment you should go
whoa that's that seems like a lot right
but we have to keep these numbers in
perspective
and so for example here's the lhc i'm
gonna you know i'm gonna have these
relative
uh costs that are uh you know that are
related that are directly proportional
the size of the ring
so the lhc cost about eight billion
dollars to construct
and it costs less in fact it's a lot
less than one billion per year to
operate it's something like half to 600
or 700 something like that
and so the u.s department of energy
total budget this is a couple years ago
is about 30 billion per year
and the nsf is about 7.5 and the
contribution to the lhc itself from
those sources is something like 770
million
so per year that's okay that's pretty
small compared to those
those big things but it's you know it's
non-zero right
and you know just to put it also in
perspective the arts and humanities get
about 300 million per year and it's
proposed to go to 71 million and then
down to zero
uh by the current administration by
contrast
the entire budget of the us military is
700 billion dollars per year
also if you take all of the companies
that are
private companies that are current or
even public that are currently evaluated
at
over one billion dollars something like
you know they call these unicorns
these are 650 billion dollars
so if we as a society valued scientific
curiosity
as much as we valued uh you know making
bombs so that saudi arabia could bomb
yemen
we would be able to right now we could
build a particle collider on
around the circumference of the moon and
we could definitely answer answer many
of these questions now
well that's where we should combine you
know these department of defense type
things and we should get space force
involved i mean
imagine if we have space force james
you're you're thinking too small
no uh i have a different perspective we
should cut this budget by about
75 and give that money to science basic
science
well so that's that brings up a question
uh so we've got about 10 minutes left i
want to ask a question just before it
gets too late for me to ask questions
and then i have a whole bunch of
questions from my friends online
um so first question is that i i always
think about is
when i don't know if you were what what
how old you are what age you are but i
remember clearly on
basically the first day of graduate
school in 1993
a whole bunch of particle physics is
moping around the
sixth floor of barristan holly building
at brown university
go bears where i was a graduate student
along with jerry geraldnick
who is one of the you know pioneers
behind the theory of what became known
as the higgs particle
about those politics i talk about in my
book he was a lovely uh
human being and i miss him terribly but
anyway he was mopping around all my
other particle physics professors were
moping around because they cancelled the
super conducting super collider that day
and i remember thinking wow what's the
big deal you know now it's just whatever
billion dollars it was estimated to cost
and now that i'll just come flooding
back into science and we'll get you know
i'll get a bigger telescope out of my
you know and we'll get
uh you know a telescope in every pot uh
of course it didn't come to be i was
very naive i was very
uh immature back then yeah and so uh i
think you know a lot of the people
you know most notably folks like sabine
hussenfelder who i've had on the show
she'll say things like well that's not
really a good argument that once you
throw the money away
uh or once the money goes away from from
one project it
it uh it doesn't go into physics general
it's not fungible within physics it's
fungible within budgets for countries
um so how do you respond to that i mean
the fact is
that if it didn't happen uh there are of
course other uses for it
uh you know solving different problems
in science not
by deploying the particle physicist to
solve those problems i know
i know you don't believe that but uh but
you know what do you make of it i mean
once once these things
are cancelled they it's not like there's
some windfall for the rest of physics so
to speak so
how do you handle that where you know
the money's not fungible but on the
other hand
it is a big price tag and you can always
you know fund it if that's a word for
some other project like you have arts
and humanities etc
there yeah i mean two two answers to
that one is that i
you know i completely agree that you
know that's just not the way science
funding works i mean
there isn't some magic switch that says
you know all this money that is going to
possibly go to particle physics it's
going to go to some other science
project
you know either basic science or you
know public policy projects something
like that
that's that's not that's it doesn't work
that one-to-one way
you're right that it does in some sense
free up funds if something like this did
not go through so it's entirely possible
they actually see
at some point some people decide man
it's not really worth the money so let's
you know let's let's cancel it
but that doesn't there's no guarantee
that that'll go directly as you pointed
out into
other science experiments and so i think
that you know the
the possibility of going to other
projects yeah i mean i i'm not sure what
to
to say about that yes of course
absolutely the money could be used for
something
else but in this case it has a very very
coherent plan and has a very very clear
you know uh reason to exist which is to
explore the unknown
and again i hate to keep harping upon
this but if we as a species
if we give this type of thing up we're
giving up on one of the key things that
makes us human
which is curiosity about nature and you
know i can think of it in terms of it's
almost
it's it's almost bizarre to my
colleagues and i when we see these um
these you know occasional sort of like
news stories or quotes about people that
are like oh it's too expensive and
you know oh you know there's no clear
plan and oh there's no guarantee as to
what you're gonna find it's like
if you knew what you're gonna get in
advance you wouldn't call it an
experiment
that's really what it is and i think
that the way that we have
you know that we have accustomed
ourselves to explaining why these big
projects are important
is it does a disservice to the truth
behind the science itself
it's you know we can take a we can take
a um a cue from our
astronomer colleagues for example you
know the 30 meter telescope i mean you
know we can talk about the politics of
that some other time and i'd be happy to
talk about that it's very interesting
but to explain the need for a 30 meter
telescope what did they say
like we need this so we can see things
that we currently can't
see and that's it that's it that's great
and it's the same thing with a bigger
collider
because one of the things we didn't talk
about is when you go to higher energies
you're actually actually able to resolve
at smaller and smaller distance scales
it's also a thing you get for free and
that's not based upon theory that's just
physics
that's just like reality so if we want
to resolve
things look at structure of nature
smaller than say 10 to the minus 18
meters
that's why we build bigger machines so
in that case it's like
this is the just justification the
motivation for these experiments
um and the the other part is uh
no i think i can combine both the
answers into one yeah
yeah i mean i think it's a little bit um
you know oversimplifying it to say that
we need money for other things therefore
we shouldn't spend money on this
on the other hand you could say there's
only so much total funding
available in the universe of ideas and
then you could further subdivide it
i'm speaking behind me is now a zoom
background for
a project uh equivalent of the you know
the final
experiment in the cmb field called this
cosmic microwave background stage force
s4 experiment which is a grand
collaboration of
costing perhaps 600 billion dollars to
construct
uh post construction you know of the
simon's observatory which i co-lead with
uh
about 300 of the smartest people on
earth uh i i think i have to say
uh i you know the best part of science
is that you get to work with these
incredibly clever
in my case and theorists and observers
and i always think you know as an
experimentalist we have to know the
theory extremely well we just don't have
to create new theories
and so i think it's important as some
people are asking in in the
comments section you know you should be
guided by theory
but but also you kind of have to go a
little bit as as we say into the
impossible into the unknown
and how you know how do we know if we're
going to achieve
a limit of uh you know of the capability
of these colliders to really reveal
something new in other words
could it just could is it possible this
is you know not putting you on the
witness stand
but let's say we build it we build
everything that you're looking for
and we come up with nothing uh in terms
of like we don't discover a new particle
we don't discover new forces
is would that be uh would that and we
have to i before i
ask your answer you know uh would that
be a failure
i have to say this comes up in the cmb
community as well we have
simply no idea whether or not inflation
took place or whether the universe has
cyclic
attributes to it and would therefore not
produce observable amounts of
gravitational radiation
we don't know but we're going to do it
or building bigger experiments but
there's a limit i don't think
there's you know quite the appetite for
you know 100 you know 20 billion dollar
experiment as a 600
million dollar experiment still a lot of
money right but will it would you say
it's a failure
uh i believe in some cases if you look
at the question in a certain way
i could make the argument it would be a
failure to spend a lot of money on a
cosmology experiment if it doesn't
detect something but on the other hand
we have things we're guaranteed to
detect so it's a long-winded way of
saying
um is it possible that the that a future
collider such as the one
being proposed in europe would that uh
come up empty and would you
james beach him consider that a failure
in some sense
obviously technically it would be yeah
go ahead sorry no please
well so the answer is absolutely not the
to qualify to describe an experiment as
a failure
um to me it has to uh actually fail
which means that for example the
experiment has to explode when you
didn't want it to or you know the mirror
has to crack suddenly into a million
pieces when that was not intended
or the uh someone passes a gigantic
electromagnet
on all of the redundant copies of your
data and it's all gone that's a failure
but the large hadron collider for
example has only discovered a higgs
boson
but does that mean that otherwise it's
been a failure absolutely not again
every single one of these papers that we
in data analyses that we do
every single one of them that validates
the standard model is brand new
information about the universe that we
didn't have before we literally
did not have that information and now we
do that is huge that is gigantic and as
you know
you know as a physicist null results can
be fantastic game changers
you know the mickelson morley experiment
all these things can really really
fantastically change things
and so again i i have to like push back
and be the hardcore sort of like yes
let's explore and that you know just the
fact that we explore is a big big thing
however to leave you with this to answer
in a more concrete way
the answer is that along the way there
are tons of things that we will be
measuring and these are specific
standard model properties that we
currently don't know about
in the standard model and one of the big
ones for example is related to this
higgs boson
we talked slightly about how you know
there's this you've probably seen this
kind of like
champagne bottle you know style
potential for the higgs boson right and
it kind of goes like this and it goes up
like that and then the minimum is down
here at non-zero so therefore you get
massive particles blah blah blah
and that's really interesting to know
however there is
unknown information about that potential
that we can potent that we can in fact
measure precisely at future machines
like these gigantic circular colliders
and that information could be that
possibly
this potential does not just shape like
this in fact it could go
here and then curve over on the edges at
the very extreme
and this part over here could in fact be
more minimum
or could be minimal compared to the
thing that we see the higgs boson in
right now
so what that means is that we're living
our universe
possibly lives in a false vacuum and
what that means is that it's entirely
possible
that our universe in the future could
the vacuum itself the vacuum of space
itself
could decay spontaneously something like
10 to the 139 years from now
but it's still in top possibly entirely
possible it could do that and it could
suddenly tunnel
to another universe and that to me is
and if we if we want to know the answer
to this we need to measure the higgs
potential down to
really really high precision and again
you know are you
are is the is that discovery going to
make uh you know an invention that makes
your feet smell better
no but what it will do is will give you
a better sense as to how
we how why we humans exist in this
universe at all
kind of the reason why you even go after
things like the cmb you know
right very good james well we're coming
up on the top of the hour i want to have
a part two with you someday if you agree
to it that would be so much
fun for me and uh before i leave because
we don't know what will come of the
future
in these highly uncertain times so i'm
going to ask you a question that i ask
nobel prize winners billionaire hedge
fund managers
pulitzer prize winners i ask all my
guests this uh
question and it relates to the title of
this podcast into the impossible which
you pointed out it's one of arthur c
clarke's three famous laws first one
being any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
magic
second one being for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
i see you
and i see sabine and you're doing these
things
but the third one is the only way to
know what is possible is to venture a
bit beyond into the impossible
tell my audience something that you
thought was impossible once maybe as a
20 year old 30 year old version of james
and then you went ahead and did it and
so it became possible
by virtue of your courage and ability to
go into the into the impossible
yeah so well i'll just give you a
personal example for example um so
i in fact have a very strange uh career
in particle physics i
started out as a filmmaker so i have a
completely separate bachelor's degree in
film studies uh you know and just
you know experimental avant-garde style
film that's you know so i have like a
kind of an artist part of my brain
and so back when i was finishing my you
know my bachelor's degree in film
studies
i was also at the same time obsessed i
realized i was obsessed with math and
physics
and while i was making films i was also
secretly reading you know
landau on the side and i was reading you
know jackson and i was reading brian
grain and things like that
and i realized i was doing myself a
disservice if i didn't study physics and
math formally
so in fact i went back to a community
college and i did a couple of years
worth of like a year
worth of you know physics and math uh
classes and then i transferred to uc
santa cruz to do a second bachelor's
degree in physics and math
and then i did a phd in physics and now
i work at the largest experiment in
human history
pushing the boundaries of human
knowledge right to the very edge of
where human knowledge breaks down
and that probably seemed impossible to
be slightly impossible to be about i
don't know what 15 years ago
now it's real wow fantastic james you
did a great job
thank you so much for having the courage
to come on into the impossible face the
critics face the
the the questioners and i hope the
audience will tune in for a part two and
what may
uh may we do it soon and i wish you the
best there stay healthy
uh stay sane stay sanitized and we will
uh catch up with you later thanks james
have a great day
thanks for having me brian bye bye